[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Today I'm
meeting with Fatima Otori
to talk about Google
Cloud Launcher
and how I could get my site into
the cloud in less time than it
takes to order a tall Americano.
Fatima, so you work on
Google Cloud Launcher.
FATIMA OTORI: Yes, I do.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Tell us all about it.
What does it do?
FATIMA OTORI: Google
Cloud Launcher
is Google's implementation
of a software marketplace.
And what that means is it's
really an online store for VMs.
So these are VMs that run
on top of Google Cloud
Platform and host
or represent some
of the popular
applications that you,
as an individual developer,
or even businesses,
can come on there and create
solutions for what they need.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So for example,
if I want to build a
website with WordPress,
it's going to give me
everything for that?
FATIMA OTORI: Yes, exactly.
So in Cloud Launcher
today, we're
hosting a number of
software packages.
Popular like WordPress,
and then other ones
that are more
enterprise related.
And so you can go
on there and you
can find a WordPress VM
that's really, essentially,
been preconfigured for you.
And so within a
few clicks, you can
be up and running with
your own personal website.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So that
can be pretty complex, right?
There's the virtual machine
with it's operating system,
and you're going to
have the language,
like PHP, the database, the
software, and all the bits
to link it all together.
And that can be done with
one click type launch?
FATIMA OTORI: Yes.
So the advantage for
Launcher is exactly
to take away that complexity
from the end user.
And so when these VMs
are packaged and supplied
by our third party providers,
they take care of all that
for you.
So they come preconfigured
with the OS, the database,
and any other
application dependencies
that you would need.
So if you're running
WordPress, your MySQL instance
is already preconfigured
in that VM.
And so for you as an end
user, you can really get up
and running within a few clicks.
You do have the flexibility to
pick the size of your VM, which
is the size of your machine,
based on how much you
think your workload will be.
But within a few
clicks, you can deploy
and you can have a WordPress
site up and running.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That is really cool.
Because I've built a few
WordPress sites in my time,
and it's all that plumbing and
all that getting stuff to work.
It's worth it in the end,
because it's terrific,
but it's a lot of fiddlings.
FATIMA OTORI: It is.
And Cloud Launcher is really
the easiest way for end users
to explore Google
Cloud Platform.
And for that reason.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So can I put you on the
spot and ask you to demo it?
FATIMA OTORI: Of course.
That's why I brought my laptop.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You came prepared.
FATIMA OTORI: I came prepared.
So let me just log into
my machine right now.
And so if you can see, I'm
just going to easily access
the Cloud Launcher site by going
to cloud.google.com/launcher.
That brings you to
our cloud store.
As you can see, we're featuring
a number of popular packages
up top.
But if you know what
you're looking for,
like WordPress, we also have
a search bar where you can go
and type in WordPress.
And you can see your different
options for WordPress.
And so here you have
three different options.
One for running just a
single website, and then
a multi-site WordPress instance.
And so you're free
to select either one.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well,
I'm not popular enough
to have a multi-site.
So I think I'll just
stick with the single one.
FATIMA OTORI: That's fine.
OK, so I'm going to select
the single site WordPress VM.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
FATIMA OTORI: As we
mentioned before,
you can see on the
right-hand side here
what's contained in this VM.
So it tells you what
operating system is included.
It also gives you information
about the database
that's been preconfigured.
The one that I selected
is an open source version
of WordPress-- so
WordPress is open source--
and so there's no pricing
attached to the image itself.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
FATIMA OTORI: Of course, there
is still the underlying compute
costs, and so--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's why we're
asked to pick the
different machine size.
FATIMA OTORI: Exactly.
And so we give you an estimate
of pricing here as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
FATIMA OTORI: As
you'll see on the site,
we now have commercial solutions
on Cloud Launcher where
there is a cost for
licensing those things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I assume
some operating systems also
have a cost
associated with them--
FATIMA OTORI: Oh, that's true.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --and that
would be included there.
OK.
Really neat.
So let's build a WordPress.
FATIMA OTORI: Yeah.
And so as you can
see, you scroll down.
And really what's
contained on this site
is tutorials and documentations
on how to get started.
But if you're
comfortable with that,
you can simply click
this button that
says Launch on Compute Engine.
And so we've done that.
And it's opening up
my Developer console.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Associate
it with a project.
FATIMA OTORI: Exactly.
And so I'll just go and
pick a project of mine.
And so--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I like
the icon, the little rocket.
FATIMA OTORI: Oh, yes.
We thought that was cute.
And so now, before I hit
the button to deploy,
if I want to give my
deployment a new name, I can.
I select the zone that I want
my instance to be spun up on.
And my machine size,
I have flexibility
to select that as well.
I'll just go ahead and
pick a more sizable image.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Because you're
going to have a popular site.
FATIMA OTORI: Yes, of course.
And then I also have
my choice of disk.
I'll leave it as is.
And then you have some
networking firewall options
as well, which I won't
change at the time.
So I go ahead and click Deploy.
And give that a few
minutes to pop up.
Cloud Launcher now supports
Deployment Manager internally.
And so what this
allows you to do
is to be able to save
any configuration
of your environment
that you've created,
and use that template anywhere
else on Google Cloud Platform.
Also, if you're
doing more than just
deploying single
VM instance, you
can easily manage it
through this config UI
to specify how many instances of
a particular solution you want.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And now
it's just creating everything,
right?
FATIMA OTORI: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Setting up the VM,
setting up the-- I see
the firewall on the--
FATIMA OTORI: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
FATIMA OTORI: So while
that is spinning up,
I just want to go point out
some of the other commercial
solutions that we have
available on Launcher.
So I'll click Enterprise
DB, which is our Enterprise
Postgres option in Launcher.
And I just wanted to point out,
so this one is not open source.
It actually has a
price attached to it.
But just as you saw, you can see
the breakdown of the pricing.
And so this is actually
strong for our users
because they want to know what
they're paying for before they
actually invest.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Help you
to budget up front, right?
FATIMA OTORI: Exactly.
And with this solution, you
can get full documentation
and tutorials of how to use
this particular solution.
And you also have a direct
link to our partner support.
And so if you want
to call support,
here's a link for you to do so.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
FATIMA OTORI: And so
it's up and running.
And I'll just go ahead and
actually just go to the site
itself.
And here you go.
Your blog is up and running.
Of course, you have the Admin
console if you want to go
and actually publish
content or design your blog
however you want it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Really from nothing,
you have a full
WordPress-based infrastructure
built in just a few minutes.
FATIMA OTORI: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So this
is great stuff for me
as a developer, but what
if I'm an enterprise?
What if I have a lot of
these things to deploy?
Is there an offering?
FATIMA OTORI: Actually,
that's a very good question,
because traditionally,
of course,
developers are always
chomping at the bit
to see what's the
latest and greatest.
But you know,
surprisingly, we're
seeing that enterprises are
coming to or taking advantage
of marketplace such
as Cloud Launcher
to test out your new solutions.
Not only to test,
but also when they
do get ready to deploy
something in production,
they can do that right from
the Cloud Launcher today.
And so today in Cloud Launcher,
we are hosting just single VMs,
but we have now
Deployment Manager.
And so think of
Deployment Manager
as the enabler to deploying
many, many instances
versus just that one.
Which is what enterprises
are looking for.
Not only deployment, being able
to manage it centrally as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And it's a great way
to test a new software
stack without investing
in all the hardware, right?
FATIMA OTORI: That's
exactly right.
And we see enterprises taking
advantage of that as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Interesting.
So where do you fit into
all of this, Fatima?
What do you do here at Google?
FATIMA OTORI: Yeah.
So I work on a team called
the Google Cloud Partner Team.
And our main job,
our sole job, is
to bring the best
of breed partners
to Google Cloud Platform
to enable our end users
freedom of choice.
I work primarily
with the partners
that we onboard onto
the Cloud Launcher.
And we do everything from
verifying these packages,
making sure that
they're up-to-date
and they are what
they say-- they
do what they say they will
do on Google Cloud Platform.
So we work with partners
to bring that solution
to the store, but then we also
help them spread their message,
and what the right way
to use the solution
is to the end user.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Actually, you
bring up an interesting point,
because when you're
saying it's like you want
to verify that it's
the right thing,
like if I'm getting WordPress,
that really is WordPress.
But what also then
happens, like if I--
we've now just built a
WordPress site together.
What happens then when
WordPress gets updated?
Do I need to go and
start fiddling to update?
FATIMA OTORI: No,
that's a good question.
And I think this is something
that separates the experience
that users get from
using Cloud Launcher
versus some other marketplaces
they may know out there.
And so going back to what we
do as a Cloud Platform Partner
Team, all the partners
that we bring on board,
we make sure that it's not just
a transactional relationship,
right?
The images they provide
for us in the store,
we make sure that when they
do have an update on there,
they notify Google.
I like to use the
analogy of an app store.
Today when you go to an app
store, you download an app.
You install it on your phone.
When there are updates,
you get push notification.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
FATIMA OTORI: Same
thing on Cloud Launcher.
We make sure that our partners
are able to adequately notify
any of the users who's using
their solution on Cloud
Launcher.
And so this is the
support mechanism
that we've built
into Cloud Launcher.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Very cool.
So yeah, because like if
I'm building something,
I've got multiple pieces
of software in the stack.
There's the operating system,
the language, the database,
the software tool itself.
And any of these can have
security patches, and that--
FATIMA OTORI: Yeah, exactly.
That's one of the
main, if I could say,
disadvantages of using
some software marketplaces,
because traditionally, what
we've seen is that people go
and they deploy software.
The first version is great.
And they're happy, and their
project is up and running.
But pretty soon, security
vulnerabilities pop up
and they don't get notified.
And so essentially,
we say from the second
they deploy that software,
it's essentially dead, right?
And we're trying to avoid that
problem with Cloud Launcher.
And so they would
get automatic updates
if there's any change to the
solution that they're running.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So yeah.
If I'm an IT admin and
I've got hundreds of sites
that I'm looking after, one
personal WordPress site is one
thing, but if I've
got hundreds of them,
I need to know which
ones are working,
which ones need updates.
And so you're pushing
updates about that to me.
FATIMA OTORI: Yes, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's really cool.
How would I get
started if I want
to build my own
WordPress instead
of having you do it for me?
FATIMA OTORI: You can go up
to cloud.google.com/launcher
and create your
own Google account.
And you have free will
to use what you see there
in the Cloud Store.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
So cloud.google.com/launcher.
So go check it out now.
Maybe you'll build a
wonderful site on WordPress
or on something else.
So please let us know if
you've any questions for me
or if you've any
questions for Fatima.
Let us know on the
comments below.
And we'd love to
see what you build.
Thank you.